pas cuire deux députés qui veulent en
finir avec un scandale français le
manque cruel de médecin sur le
territoire les déserts médicaux touchent
une commune sur trois rendez-vous compte
c'est près du 8 millions de personnes
qui galèrent pour se faire soigner alors
faut-il les obliger les médecins de
ville et bien à s'installer dans les
zones où l'on manque le plus de médecins
Marco Polini nous résume leur deux
propositions de loi avant d'accueillir
Guillaume Garraud et Frédéric va le tout
juste après
si on vous invite Guillaume Garraud et
Frédéric valthou c'est pour un duel
alors ce soir rassurez-vous pas d'épée
ou de pistolet mais seulement des
arguments des idées pour lutter contre
les déserts médicaux vos remèdes
apparaissent bien différents et c'est
pourtant un débat crucial pour 8
millions de Français trouvaient un
médecin relève du parcours du combattant
et je mets une heure et quart pour venir
voir mon médecin on préférerait avoir
les médecins sur place mais bon vu les
contextes actuels
Frédéric valtoux vous êtes député
horizon de Seine-et-Marne proche
d'Edouard Philippe quant à vous
Guillaume Garraud vous êtes député
socialiste élu dans la Mayenne troisième
désert médical du pays cet hiver vous
avez lancé un tour de France des déserts
médicaux avec une quarantaine de députés
issus de 9 groupes politiques de la
France insoumise aux républicains en
passant par la majorité des réunions
publiques aux quatre coins du pays pour
défendre une proposition phare la
régulation de l'installation des
médecins en fonction des besoins des
territoires autrement dit vous touchez à
la sacro-sainte liberté d'installation
des années que je me bats l'Assemblée
pour que on change les règles de
l'exercice et de l'installation de nos
médecins en France un point faible votre
proposition loi n'est même pas inscrite
à l'ordre du jour de l'assemblée à
l'inverse de la vôtre Frédéric valthoux
nous nous devons d'agir autant
rapidement qu'en cherchant l'efficacité
votre texte débattu en commission cette
semaine à le soutien du gouvernement de
votre côté pas question de régulation
vous voulez faire confiance aux acteurs
de terrain les professionnels de santé
les mers pour régler les problèmes
d'accès aux soins aujourd'hui notre
problème principal c'est le manque de
soignants si on crée des solutions qui
nous paraissent belles sur le papier qui
nous paraissent huilés théoriquement
mais qui n'emmène pas les professionnels
alors on n'aura pas réussi à régler le
problème de l'accès aux soins parce
qu'on c'est qu'une chose c'est être
dégoûté et à détourner des
professionnels qui sont déjà pas assez
nombreux pour répondre à la demande deux
propositions loi pour un même combat
alors on a une question pour vous
messieurs face à l'urgence pourquoi
avez-vous échoué à vous mettre d'accord
en voilà une question pertinente bonsoir
Frédéric baltoux merci d'être là député
horizon de Seine-et-Marne c'est votre
proposition de loi soutenue par la
majorité qui est débattu en commission
cette semaine vous faites face ce soir à
Guillaume Garo bonsoir député socialiste
de la Mayenne votre proposition elle est
transpartisane puisqu'elle est soutenue
aussi par une petite partie voire une
bonne partie de la majorité qui soutient
aussi la vôtre donc la question de Marco
Pollier elle est évidemment pertinente
pourquoi deux propositions le scandale
des déserts médicaux ne mérite pas que
vous vous accordiez dans l'hémicycle ah
moi je considère qu'on n'a pas du tout
échoué à se mettre d'accord d'abord
parce que un
on a tous on a tous été élu locaux on
est tous élus de territoire qui
souffrent sur le plan médical et on sait
que les solutions elles sont
pragmatiques et que personne n'a la
baguette magique et donc c'est
simplement un dialogue un débat pour
essayer de trouver finalement les
solutions qui seront les plus efficaces
vous pourriez voter celle de Guillaume
Garraud
on s'entend sur plein de sujets et on
est d'accord sur plein de sujets il peut
y avoir dans les dispositions que les
uns les autres nous souhaitons certaines
dispositions et la régulation
d'installation en études par exemple qui
nous différencie mais il y a pas de
toute façon
l'installation ça ne changerait pas le
sujet des médicaments
faut être très clair il s'agit d'obliger
les médecins à s'installer là où on
manque le plus de médecins non non c'est
pas ça c'est pas ça alors c'est quoi
précisément
ce débat et votre émission pour juste
préciser les choses qu'est-ce que nous
entendons nous dans notre proposition de
loi transpartisanes c'est-à-dire qu'il y
a aujourd'hui plus plus de 200 députés
issus de tous les groupes républicains
de l'Assemblée ça va dever les filles
jusqu'à LR qui ont consigné cette
proposition de loi et qu'est-ce que nous
entendons par régulation une chose toute
simple nous disons à nos médecins aux
médecins écouter n'allez plus vous
installer là où les besoins de santé
sont déjà pourvus là où l'offre de soins
est correctement assurée comment vous
faites si vous les obligez pas et bien
je vais terminer mon raisonnement
n'allez plus vous installer ici mais
vous pourrez vous installer où vous
voulez ailleurs là où il y a des besoins
de santé donc on encadre en effet cette
liberté d'installation
l'encadre voilà on la régule c'est bien
le sens que vous avez la régulation
madame Kawa elle existe pour toutes les
autres ou beaucoup d'autres professions
de santé les pharmaciens ne s'installent
pas exactement là où ils veulent il y a
des règles à respecter en fonction de ce
qu'on appelle un bassin de population du
nombre d'habitants nous proposons pour
les médecins une solution qui n'est pas
évidemment la même mais qui dans
l'esprit permet de dire ce qui compte
aujourd'hui c'est de répondre aux
besoins de santé la régulation elle se
freine dans votre proposition de loi par
les agences régionales de santé qui
regardent la carte il y a des zones
dotées d'ailleurs on va la regarder
cette carte des déserts médicaux sur des
sur la médecine générale c'est
intéressant parce que tout ce qui est
très clair en rose pâle c'est là où on
manque le plus de médecins on voit bien
que c'est pas uniquement les campagnes
c'est pas uniquement les zones rurales
l'Île-de-France cruellement de médecins
on est à 8 médecins pour pour 10000
habitants si c'est l'ARS qui décide ça
se passe comment
ça se passe sur la base d'une
cartographie on a vu une carte à
l'instant à l'écran ça signifie que et
d'ailleurs je suis heureux que nous
ayons pu le voter par amendement en
commission nous créons un indicateur
territorial de l'offre de soins ça veut
dire qu'on regarde bassin de vie après
bassin de vie territoire vit la vraie
ville ce qu'il en est de la réalité de
l'offre de soins est-ce que on a
suffisamment de médecins généralistes
est-ce que on a suffisamment dermato ou
d’œufs
décide d'envoyer un médecin là où on en
a le plus besoin s'il ne le fait pas
qu'est-ce qui se passe je vous ai dit
l'inverse je viens de vous dire que on
autorisait pas l'installation là où les
besoins de santé sont déjà pourvus
ensuite ben voilà mais donc on dit au
médecin mais allez vous installer où
vous voulez ailleurs on l'a vu sur la
sur la carte à l'instant il y a des
zones qui sont en rose pâle d'autres ou
manifestement voilà
descends le dire à aller là où on en a
besoin et bien par les politiques
d'incitation les politiques d'incitation
qui existent déjà mais qui aujourd'hui
n'ont pas rempli leur office pourquoi
parce que quand on est un jeu de médecin
ou un médecin déjà expérimenté on va
exactement là où on a envie d'aller sans
tenir compte forcément des besoins de la
population et c'est ça que nous
remettons en cause il faut partir des
besoins de santé
alors partir du territoire regardez là
où on en manque le plus et faire en
sorte qu'on régule qu'on flèche et qu'on
incite c'est du bon sens non aujourd'hui
c'est le problème majeur mais priorité
des Français et des Allemands opposé à
l'idée d'orienter les jeux de médecins
vers les zones effectivement où on a
besoin d'eux c'est logique et normal
quand on est médecin on est dans une
activité en plus qui est financée ou
solvabiliser par la solidarité nationale
il n'est pas illégitime que la nation
dise
à ceux qui sert un système qui est qui
le finance les objectifs qui sont les
siens et donc d'aller plutôt soigner de
remettre en cause de liberté
d'installation là où on veut la liberté
d'installation bon d'accord mais pas à
tout prix le problème pour moi il est
pas là aujourd'hui le problème il est
que on est dans une période où on sait
qu'on a et on aura pendant 5 à 10
prochaines années de moins en moins de
soignants et malheureusement des besoins
de soins qui vont aller en augmentant et
que parce que former des médecins c'est
dans le temps long que les courbes ne
vont pas s'inverser comme ça du jour au
lendemain et qu'à partir de là on doit
gérer pendant 5 à 10 ans la pénurie de
soignants dans les terrains
de remise en cause de cette liberté
regarder les pharmaciens c'est le cas
dans la fonction publique un jeune un
jeune diplômé du CAPES enseignant il va
dans les EPS pourquoi c'est pas au fond
le moment de le faire
loi qui a été discuté pendant pendant
deux jours de se focalisent pas que sur
cette affaire de l'installation
répartir mieux la rareté ça rendra
personne plus riche plus riche en
médecins et donc moi je veux bien qu'on
applique ce genre de méthode mais il
faudra expliquer aux Français que il
trouveront des résultats dans les 10 ans
qui viennent mais pas avant donc c'est
pour ça que j'ai essayé de faire de
mettre en avant un certain nombre de
propositions pour aider effectivement à
ce que par exemple sur la permanence des
soins l'idée de trouver plus facilement
un médecin en début de soirée le
week-end le
urgent les jours fériés oui pour les
soins urgents pour les les besoins
immédiats effectivement et bien on
puisse effectivement mieux faire
participer plus faire participer
l'ensemble des soignants
une garde par exemple à l'hôpital comme
on l'a fait pendant le covid
effectivement plus équitablement sur les
médecins de vie là aujourd'hui il y a 40
% des médecins généralistes qui
participent à la permanence des sons à
d'ores et déjà donc dans les dans leur
cabinet il y a des cabinets qui sont
ouvert le week-end moi j'en connais il y
a des cabinets qui sont ouverts les
jours fériés c'est pas les plus nombreux
40% participent à la performance des
soins ça veut dire que la 60% d'autres
qui les regardent faire
la permanence des soins
et puis et puis jusqu'à présent on avait
aussi extrait de la permanence des soins
les cliniques et donc par notre
proposition loi et des dispositions
d'ailleurs qui a été voté je crois à
l'unanimité en tout cas de manière assez
large à la Commission
de demain les les techniques
participeront à la permanence des soins
c'est-à-dire dans ces périodes creuses
en dehors de des ouvertures des horaires
classiques d'ouverture les cliniques et
bien seront susceptibles d'accueillir
les les urgences c'est à dire que qu'un
blessé urgent
qui qui a ramassé par le SAMU au bord de
la dune accident de voiture pourra
peut-être emmené dans un territoire dans
sur un plateau technique de clinique là
où aujourd'hui neuf fois sur 10 il est
emmené à l'hôpital et donc on soulagera
aussi les hôpitaux de cette charge qui
est la parole il y a aussi besoin d'une
des causes de la surcharge des hôpitaux
c'est vraiment le désert médical c'est
vraiment le manque de médecin de ville
ou de prise en charge ailleurs qu'à
l'hôpital sur ces deux points permanence
des soins et on met à contribution les
cliniques privées là vous êtes d'accord
bien sûr et d'ailleurs moi j'ai voté en
commission ces dispositions là mais ce
que je dis aussi à Frédéric valthou
c'est que il ne faut se priver d'aucune
solution
ne se priver d'aucun levier et la
régulation en est un je dis pas que
c'est la solution magique à tous nos
problèmes ce serait évidemment beaucoup
trop simple mais avec la coercition
est-ce qu'il y a des sanctions si les
ARS une fois qu'elles ont fléchés les
territoires voilà qui nécessitent à
envisager aussi bien évidemment mais
concrètement
dans le débat en effet nous allons nous
déposer nos amendements pour la séance
publique qui arrive à partir de lundi je
vous ai dit qu'elle était le la démarche
le dispositif ce qu'il faut bien
comprendre c'est que on a besoin de ce
dispositif de régulation pour que tout
le reste fonctionne parce que depuis si
on prend un tout petit peu de recul
depuis 20 ans 30 ans on a essayé
beaucoup de politiques d'incitation on a
dit on va faire des chèques alors on a
fait des chèques ce sont des aides et
d'ailleurs on a réussi en commission à
faire en sorte que
on limite le plafond des aides et que on
lutte contre les conférences en incitant
ça ne suffit plus pour vous exactement
il faut il faut donc réguler pour que ça
permette au reste des mesures d'être
efficace alors vous vous les connaissez
bien les médecins vous avez fait
quelques coups de griffe vous étiez le
président de la Fédération des hôpitaux
de France il y a un gros lobby des
médecins généralistes en France il est
même puissant à l'Assemblée quand on
touche je prends le terme de régulation
à cette liberté d'installation
immédiatement il y a des menaces de
représailles de déconventionnement etc
c'est pour ça que vous vous êtes plutôt
sur une démarche de confiance et
d'incitation moi j'essaie de trouver un
chemin de pragmatisme c'est pour ça
qu'aujourd'hui
je suis intéressé par la régulation mais
je le redis à partir du moment où
effectivement il y aura suffisamment de
jeunes professionnels qui rentrent dans
la carrière pour réellement faire de la
régulation aujourd'hui 87% de la de la
France est un désert médical donc je
vous dis on rendra personne plus riche
en médecins
avant de les obliger un lobby médical
oui bien sûr
il y a une déconnexion aussi de ce que
preuve les syndicats de médecins
libéraux je parle des médecins libéraux
parce que quand on parle des médecins
les médecins hospitaliers comprennent
tout à fait le service de l'intérêt
général comprennent tout à fait
qu'effectivement il y a des modes
d'exercices et qui doivent répondre à
des attentes aussi de la Nation par
rapport à ce système de santé peut-être
on a été ces dernières années trop lâche
avec et pas assez courageux vis-à-vis du
médecine libérale qui a qu'on n'a pas
aidé à évoluer et qu'on a quand même
parfois conforté dans des modes de de de
d'exercice qui aujourd'hui peuvent les
mettre en décalage par rapport aux
attentes de la nation et donc il faut
arriver à les sortir d'un certain
individualisme et les jeunes générations
ne comprennent très bien il n'évoque
plus leur avenir dans un exercice
individuel il faut arriver à leur faire
comprendre que voilà ils sont partie
prenant d'une chaîne de prise en charge
les mentalités il faut essayer
vous avez juste des différences de
moyens pour y parvenir heureusement on
est d'accord sur l'objectif quand même à
savoir lutter contre les déserts
médicaux moi c'est un combat que que je
mène depuis plusieurs années et j'ai
acquis la conviction qu'on ne pouvait
pas s'en tenir aux solutions qui jusqu'à
présent ont été mises en oeuvre mais à
l'évidence ne sont pas il faut aller
plus fort
du volontarisme pour ceux qui nous
regardent c'est vraiment une priorité
pour les Français la question de l'accès
aux soins et de cette égalité d'accès
sur le territoire
qu'est-ce qui va se passer là vous allez
voter en partie c'est la semaine
prochaine dans l'hémicycle c'est ça
que les les articles proposés
recueilleront
plus tard sur la régulation
et chaque député prend ces
responsabilités et puis on verra
où ce qu'il en ressort cet article sur
l'arrêt de régulation ou sur un
amendement de gamegaro vous le voterez
non je dis que je le voterai pas j'ai
expliqué pourquoi
et je veux dire je ne sentirai pas je
n'aurais pas l'impression que mon projet
est totalement déstabilisé si si
l'amendement passe mais chacun pas votre
an responsabilité c'est intéressant
d'entendre de députés qui ont même
objectif qui voit les choses légèrement
différemment et pas si loin on verra ce
que ça donne et je vous propose de
revenir après après ce débat dans
l'hémicycle merci à vous